have you ever had this weird pact with
Google slides I've been having it since
yesterday with the show anyway but if I
just keep on pressing a show anyway it
shows that anyway so I will just do that
so my talk is called your regional PI
data needs you so I was just wondering I
mean this is a cool conference but has
any of you ever visited like your
regional PI data meetup before that's
cool it's like 30 percent ish I just
want you guys to be like aware that
there's like lots of local chapters of
PI data and they like host regular
events all across Germany and Europe and
the world basically and they can be a
lot of fun one question is anybody here
from Hanover Hanover raise your hand
there's like one guy from the Nova over
there
there's no meet up in Hanover but good
for you I added a link where you can
start a meet-up so you're welcome it's
really really easy to start your own
local branch of Pi data if there's none
around it's it's very informal and we're
usually very very easy to work with why
do I say we because I actually
participate in organizing PI data suit
vest which course contains Heidelberg
cards who were and Mannheim and right
now we have 846 members my new year's
resolution was to have 1,000 members I
was who could I possibly talk to to have
1,000 members by the end of the year by
the way at the end of this talk there
will be a QR code I know it takes a
little bit to start your QR code app on
your phone so maybe you want to do that
now so I just want to show you a couple
of pictures we have one awesome speaker
we have even more awesome speakers and
and cool awesome speakers like her as
well we have many many many speakers and
we have also really cool people we have
a really nice community and this is
basically how a local like PI data
meetup can look like it's very fun it's
very very convenient there's free food
as well and we have like one really big
fan his name is Alexander he's also a
little bit involved in the organization
here
and so yeah basically to sum it up if
you want to attend your local PI data
that's great if you want to speak their
that's even better if you want to speak
at PI data to invest that's even more
better and if you want to sponsor or
organize that's possibly the best thanks
a lot to the guy from Innova so that you
guys have the time to scan this QR code
with your phone with the app that you
have I will have to speak for around 15
more seconds I looked up some director
jokes in the meantime what do you call a
tractor that can turn into a robot a
trans famour thank you that's it
[Applause]